[Musique]
vous avez fait un truc avec les
chroniques oui on a fait deux petits
clips comme vous lancez votre chaîne b2o
oms il ya deux chroniqueurs qui voit là
les seniors 2 ont retrouvé la trace anti
glace couler n'a pas trop le choix mon
pote premier clip c'est valérie benaïm a
essayé pour intégrer votre chaîne booba
oui
[Musique]
m6 ont faussé le saunier dans rodez gros
servent pas à savoir bien spes en euros
capern du gers et depuis que j'exerce on
a percé pour cela et mes partenaires
français a trouvé son flow parterre
toshiko haye le parquet montage rançon
lycopène cheveux prix mais tu veux des
gars la pêche le président défait la
belge détiendra père à l'appel 6 et
l'autre à l'appel et des sujets dans le
mais là on avoir des kilos on a surtout
barret le gars qui a vraiment le plus de
flou de l'équipe bien sûr thierry morin
c'est à dire environ us coast et il sait
danser aussi dans l'aventuré regarde
quand on rentre sur l'api on est venu
tease et lacs du pays
mais là tu le manges tu m'as créez
comment leur faire confiance et tu es le
curé les rappeurs mans vite pour tous
aux galères un jour de salaire c'est le
rugby pour l'état
je l'appuie a dit
des torrents tapis on est venu pour le
mahb au litige simon par la plaignante
est ce que tu dis
un bordel quand on entre sur la piste
dès 16h au but